[Musik]
wuchern diese Stadt hat sich ins
kollektive corona-gedächtnis eingebrannt
der Markt auf dem es die ersten Corvette
19 Fälle gegeben haben soll ist immer
noch geschlossen
die elf Millionen Einwohner hier sind im
Januar 2020 die ersten die die
chinesische Staatsführung in ihren
Wohnungen einsperrt
Friseur chiarchien darf damals raus mit
einer Sondergenehmigung weil er Ärzten
ÄrztInnen und Pflegepersonal die Haare
schneidet
Frisuren die der heute einen 50-Jährige
nicht schön findet bei denen die
corona-schutzkleidung am Nacken aber gut
abdichtet
zum Dank signieren sie seinen
Schutzanzug
ich
habe mindestens 30 bis 50 Liter
Desinfektionsmittel benutzt vor allem im
lacechant Krankenhaus
wurde im Januar 2020 gebaut in gerade
einmal zwei Wochen
1600 Betten speziell für Corvette
Patientinnen und Patienten inzwischen
ist es ungenutzt eine der wenigen
Pandemie Spuren in Wuhan
wie so viele infizierte ihn sich im
Dezember mit Corona kurz nach der
Lockerung der Regeln beim Blutspenden
ich war überrascht als ich dann auch
positiv war aber ich hatte keine Angst
im Westen wurde ja auch schon viel
früher geöffnet die Leute wollen doch
Freiheit und Leben
Freiheit und Leben dafür gehen Ende
November in vielen Städten vor allem
junge Leute auf die Straße
in diesem Ausmaß in China
außergewöhnlich
kurze Zeit später erklärt die
Staatsführung Corvette 19 plötzlich zu
einer harmlosen Erkältung und hebt die
extremen Maßnahmen auf doch das ist nur
ein Teil der Geschichte
um den anderen Teil zu erzählen sprechen
wir mit vielen lange ist keiner bereit
und sein Interview zu geben denn das ist
gefährlich
einer traut sich schließlich doch
natürlich nur anonym
zwei Tage nach der Demo kriegt er nennen
wir ihn ich hören einen Anruf
[Musik]
ein Mann ist dran er sagt er sei
Polizist er überprüft meine Daten er
hatte alles Führerschein Telefonnummer
Arbeitsstelle wann ich wo war und dann
fragte er was du bei den Protesten dabei
ich höre an sagt ja ich war dabei er hat
Angst doch schließlich habe er nichts
Verbotenes gemacht der Polizist sieht
das anders
wir haben dich auf dem Radar wenn du es
wagst so was noch mal zu machen werden
wir dich bestrafen
was das genau bedeutet für den nächsten
Job die nächste Auslandsreise weiß er
noch nicht doch er weiß er hatte Glück
im Gegensatz zu einer Freundin
ich weiß von ihrer Mutter dass sie Mitte
Dezember von der Polizei abgeholt wurde
und seitdem nicht mehr aufgetaucht ist
sie ist nicht die einzige Sophie Mack
hat eine ganze Liste veröffentlicht sie
alle wurden verhaftet haben keinen
Kontakt zu ihren Angehörigen
die Menschenrechtsaktivistin stammt aus
Hongkong dort droht ihr Gefängnis
inzwischen lebt sie in Sydney kann
freier sprechen
mindestens vier von ihnen alles junge
Frauen wurden verhaftet mit dem Vorwurf
an zettelung von Streitereien und
Erregung von Unruhe nach Artikel 293 des
chinesischen Strafrechts droht darauf
eine Strafe von bis zu fünf Jahren
Gefängnis für erste Täter es ist ein
sogenanntes catch all Delikt damit
werden abweichende Meinungen und
politische Kritik an der chinesischen
Regierung kriminalisiert
youngting hat Erfahrung damit der
Menschenrechtsaktivist lebt in den USA
in China saß er wegen eines
antidiskriminierungs-newsletters in Haft
er weiß was den Protestierenden droht
man schüchtert sie ein mit großen
Anklagen sagt das Familie und Freunde
mit reingezogen werden die Polizei sagt
ihnen dass sie selbst wenn sie frei
kommen keinen Job mehr finden werden
alle Arten von mentaler und physischer
Folter
protestierende schnellstmöglich
verschwinden lassen dafür wird Chinas
Polizei gezielt trainiert
die Zukunft hier ist ich Johann zu
unsicher er will ins Ausland trotz der
neuen Corona Freiheit
einige Zahlen dafür einen hohen Preis ja
vielleicht muss ich jetzt nicht mehr
immer und überall Maske tragen aber es
gibt Leute die einfach verschwunden sind
einfach verschwunden oder sogar tot
[Musik]
wie der Vater von zu ihm der
Menschenrechtsanwalt ist einer der
wenigen der offen darüber spricht
das Ende der Null corvette-politik ohne
Vorbereitung eine wenig immunisierte
Bevölkerung in der vor allem von den
alten nicht genug geimpft waren das
Virus hatte leichtes Spiel
offiziell bescheinigte der Arzt nicht
dass er an Corona starb er sagte es mir
nur privat
in der Statistik taucht sein Vater nicht
auf die zählt in den zwei Monaten nach
den Lockerungen gerade mal 85.000 Corona
Todesfälle in Chinas Krankenhäusern
schätzungen gehen von einer Million
Toten aus Grund dafür auch dass
überlastete Gesundheitssystem drei Jahre
lang steckte der Staat Gelder lieber in
Massentests und quarantäneeinrichtungen
die Geldbörsen der Chinesen wurden
gelehrt die der normalen Chinesen auch
die persönliche Freiheit und die Würde
der Bürger wurden weitgehend beschnitten
im Namen der solchen Prävention wurden
ihnen alle möglichen Rechte entzogen
den corona-deckmantel gibt es nicht mehr
die Unfreiheit bleibt
drei Jahre lang haben sie in China
darauf gewartet dass das Leben wieder
losgeht viele haben dafür teuer bezahlt
mit ihrer Freiheit oder sogar ihrem
Leben
[Musik]